youtubers versed verse tick talkers this
is
like so this is real this is actually
happening
yeah yeah
um huh
which is it's kind of crazy
you know actually no it's not
no it's not all they're doing is just
profiting off of what
you know like i feel like
groups of dudes just do this [ __ ] you
know
you've watched your friends fight for
what you mean like your friends have
like fought
or at least you know my friends were
like i'll box you right now or whatever
it's all just sort of for fun right so
they're just profiting from that but
the the i think the crazy part is
they're just gonna make a [ __ ] ton of
money and
most of them aren't great or
like really good fighters at all do you
think they're gonna make a [ __ ] ton of
money though like i think
that they they probably think that
they're gonna break some
pay-per-view records with this card
because i think they think more people
care about this than they actually do
you know what i'm saying
like i i'm and i'm basically saying it's
not gonna be i'm not saying it's not
gonna be interesting
like i'm probably gonna watch it i'm
saying i don't think a lot of these
people's fans want to see them fight
i don't know i think they do like at
least like faze jarvis like that's all
like
teenage [ __ ] gamer boys yeah um
yeah that's true i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna
uh who else
um who do who do we think uh taylor
holder's gonna fight
so taylor holder is
probably gonna fight ryan's toys
i think he's gonna beat the dog [ __ ] out
of ryan's toys
straight up seven year old just walk up
to him like you chose the wrong one
buddy
everyone's like that's a little messed
up that they that they put ryan's toys
on the
card right he's like eight years old
isn't he oh yeah yeah apparently he
really wanted the smoke
yeah and he's gonna get [ __ ] clapped
i'm betting against that dude
[Laughter]
oh my man gotta know my man
got a fragile chin
[Laughter]
i think the funny part is i think it
takes just so much
training because you know i like what
little i know of boxing
when my coach just turns it up even a
little bit it's so disorienting
like she's like slip you know cut
you know block whatever this might be
the pace
and then she might just pick it up a
little bit i'm like oh [ __ ] and you get
caught right
so i think what's so funny is it doesn't
it doesn't matter
like this car just doesn't matter if
borderline
they should just not train i feel that's
what i'm saying it's more of like a
street fight
i think they should just get four ounce
mma gloves
and just do this [ __ ] in someone's
backyard yeah
yeah make this like a full-on backyard
brawl that would be sick i would watch
the [ __ ] out yeah exactly
but what i don't like is the
overproduction like they're probably
going to do it in some [ __ ] stadium
and have
a uh performance and you know yeah 14.
it's not a real fight this is a backyard
brawl that's what it should be yeah
[ __ ] 14-ounce gloves covering their
entire face the whole time
getting tired after 60 seconds it's a
robbery they should just scrap it out
for real
like do you think they're all training
for this they are i took i took
a i took a breeze through a couple
people's videos
um you know some of them
don't turn their punches over when they
train which i
think is really interesting because
their trainers encourage that behavior
like some i've seen some people straight
punching like
like rock'em sock'em robot
[Laughter]
it's like dog that's not gonna work
yeah yep oh great job buddy great job
yeah and deji vs vinnie hacker that's a
weird one
yeah i don't i don't know how that's
gonna
work who do you think danny duncan's
fighting which tick tocker
uh would suck if they just picked like a
huge weight difference yeah
people just um i don't know who else
could taylor hold her fight
um let's see who could he fight
um shane dawson oh ho ho ho ho
ho people would yo what if this whole
time shane was just getting
fit as [ __ ] yeah training every training
for this yes
ripping ripping mitts insane speed
then i would definitely watch this
that would be wild
what if it's someone like what if it's
someone like mark robert or marco yeah
or whatever
yeah the nicest guy ever or like or
vsauce
vsauce here like oh taylor what nah
don't do that
don't do that don't do that oh you can't
punch vsauce you just
you just knocked out vsauce man [ __ ] is
your problem and why you gotta knock out
vsauce
or [ __ ] oh my god taylor
this is mark wiens yeah yeah i'm here to
eat some delicious punches
oh dude that'd be horrible eat here to
eat a delicious
knuckle sandwich from taylor here dude
you're just punching the [ __ ] out of
mark wiens and he's just got crazy
crazy technique he's like i eat those
oh wow buffer before the show
everyone's like what is he the host
just punching the [ __ ] out of mark wiens
he's like delicious
soft mark wiens is just no hands up just
completely avoiding every single punches
dodging every punch it just
puts them behind gonna have to do more
than that taylor
ooh delicious soft pillow punches
it's amazing that he serves them up just
so
cleanly just enough for me to get around
[Laughter]
now he continues to serve that soft
pillow punch but
i won't bite i won't bite
and then he's just looking at these
decadent cheesy
punches from taylor
[Laughter]
not a single one is landing
what if someone show like what if it's
like taylor holder versus the fine bros
like they just step in it's like a tag
team
match it's like two versus one yeah
that'd be wild
[Laughter]
um or what if it was
bell delphine just a [ __ ] straight up
hate crime
[Laughter]
what do you mean just beats on a woman
like just i'm saying if she agreed to it
oh man yeah i mean you never know
oh bro well how sick would it be it
feels like amanda nunez
just like yeah a straight-up [ __ ] pro
killer taylor's like [ __ ] wait what
dana white's on the other side like yeah
we booked amanda to come through and
[ __ ] murder you
[Laughter]
he's like what nah dude no
phone ah i heard um sorry go ahead
i just wish these guys would like box
people that actually box
it's the it's the corniest [ __ ] like
they
you know well that's what the paws are
doing yeah yeah
sorta
which side are you on youtubers verse
ticktackers
i also love i love that that you know
that's someone someone at some
promotional company being like what if
we did youtubers versus tick-tockers
then everyone could pick their favorite
platform and that's the side that they
root for it's like
ugh the most added touch [ __ ]
battle of the platforms that couldn't be
more tech entrepreneur
so true battle of the platforms first of
all no one
no one calls it that no one says
platforms platforms the average person
does not go
tick-tock is a great platform yeah no
people but people will want to side with
whatever platform
they prefer whatever platform they're
spending the most time on
[Laughter]
we'll do uh we could do yeah we could do
snapchat verse tinder
how about that
linkedin versus indeed
[Laughter]
yeah yeah so yeah there it is we're
gonna watch this for sure
yeah whole bunch of free promotion but
that's whatever dude i mean people are
gonna upload clips that's gonna be the
best part is
it's it's not like these fights are
gonna be long technical
interesting fights you know the best
that can happen is
one of them stays composed and gets a
few good shots in
yeah and i love how exaggerated things
are in a context like this like if
someone just does decent everyone's like
yo
he's got hands yeah yeah yeah yeah
so we're gonna see some people do really
poorly probably like we're gonna
definitely see some sort of knockout um
somebody's gonna catch somebody with
something unless there's something like
some egregious failure like you know
nate robinson running into a fist
i don't think so man yeah that's my big
prediction i don't think anyone's gonna
get knocked out
because knockout comes either from like
power or like
technique and i just don't think like
training for
three months six months is enough to
really like
you know be composed you know
no matter how much sparring you're doing
like that [ __ ] is i don't know
we'll see i could be wrong could be
totally wrong each one of these guys
could [ __ ] put the other one on the
mat
we'll find out i'm curious to see who
how danny does because danny used to
didn't used to be a personal trainer or
like a pt or something like that
yeah yeah so he's going to drive in
drive in the stadium on a [ __ ] like
four by four
yeah yeah this goes into the ring
he's just gonna launch it in the middle
of the ring he's gonna launch a mini
dirt bike
at his opponent and kill him pre-fight
this is how bad is like the graphic
design on this
dog come on
you know what the [ __ ] this looks like
man
what i mean this this could be a hub
thumbnail yeah yeah this looks like an
ad on the hub
yeah like this doesn't even look like
they're fighting each other
youtubers vs tick tockers who's the
better kisser
[Laughter]
they're all wet look at austin they they
photoshopped water droplets on there
sprayed his ass down yeah with the
virtual water man
you